welcome to Hannity buckle up tonight all
eyes are on the middle east early this
morning a US surveillance drone flying
above the Straits of Hormuz over
international waters shot out of the sky
by an Iranian missile this act of
aggression it's not going to stand the
president is putting the mullahs of Iran
on notice tonight they should be very
very worried this was a bad idea
take a look Iran made a big mistake this
drone was in international waters
clearly we have it all documented it's
documented scientifically not just words
and they made a very bad mistake you'll
find out you'll find out obviously you
know we're not gonna be talking too much
about it you're gonna find out they made
a very big mistake
yeah Iran made a very big mistake they
will pay but tonight the president is
clearly given the mullahs and opening to
pick up the phone and come clean and
then their hostile behavior
I like that patience what about all the
Liberals have said Donald Trump is is
Rogen we can't trust them okay he's
being very patient now after a meeting
at the White House congressional
Republicans they released this statement
quote Iran directly attacked a United
States asset over international waters
this provocation comes a week after they
attacked and destroyed two commercial
tankers in international waters there
must be a measured response to these
actions hmm how do we define measure
president Trump does not want war he
said so clearly during the campaign not
interested in another you know years and
years long international entanglement
I don't expect one but in coming days we
will know if the mullahs are smart
enough to take the opportunity which is
a small window it may not even exist
within five minutes because if they
don't the president will have no choice
he will bomb the hell out of them no
need for long protracted boots on the
ground kind of war we have the greatest
military thank God on the face of this
earth we have the most advanced weapon
systems and a strong message needs to be
sent that a huge price will be paid if
you take on the United
States of America simple peace through
strength and it works my strong opinion
it is imperative that we as a country
develop what I call the next generation
of military weaponry we have learned
from Vietnam we have learned from Iraq
and Afghanistan
sadly wars we get involved in quickly
become politicized they do not end as
they should with complete victory we
don't want our kids going door to door
like they did in Iraq and then having
Democrats saying oh come home and then
being told nevermind we didn't mean it
America needs the single most advanced
weaponry for all future conflicts I'd
much prefer we devastate our enemies
from Tampa Florida that generation of
weaponry is something we need to advance
as a country quick quickly and
expeditiously thankfully tonight we are
in a new era the weak feckless Biden
Obama foreign policy is long dead and
gone there will be no late-night
shipments of 150 billion dollars in cash
and other currency in cargo planes
headed for the mullahs in Tehran there
will be no bribes there'll be no
European frolics for John Kerry there'll
be no United Nations this is now a
different time there will be hell to pay
and the world is watching China tonight
is watching Russia tonight is watching
what happens in Iran will have
ramifications all over the world the
North Koreans are watching let this
brings us now to a quick Hannity history
lesson it is no mystery why Iran is
acting out why in 2015 how this happened
I cannot explain it is inexplicable the
single dumbest foreign policy deal ever
made in the history of this country
Biden Obama literally loosened economic
sanctions on Iran after they had a
chance to support young freedom fighters
the younger generation that wanted help
that were quoting Oh Jefferson and
Washington and our framers and founders
and yeah
Biden Obama gifted the radical Islamic
mullahs of Iran a hundred and fifty
billion dollars in cash and other
currency in exchange while the radian
government they made an unverifiable
promise not to build a nuclear weapon
for years but they can do it in ten
years
and of course the radical Islamic
extremist government of Iran continued
to fund terrorism as they always have
all over the world proxy wars they
continue to chant death to Israel death
to America they continue to burn the
American flag the Israeli flag they are
a hostile actor in the region and thanks
to Biden Obama
well they had a boatload of cash to
spend funding fomenting terror around
the world all of this change January
20th 2017 President Trump was
inaugurated he pulled the United States
out of this horrific Iranian nuclear
deal
Jiri imposed devastating sanctions and
they're working today tonight Iran
feeling the effects of the president's
policies they're feeling it in a big way
because of the reimpose sanctions they
are now facing years Long's recession
2018 their economy retracted by a
whopping 4% this year
the International Monetary Fund is
predicting the RAM will lose another six
percent the inflation also a massive
issue in Iran 2019 alone inflation
likely to top 40 percent meanwhile our
economy is booming and because of the
president's efforts to unleash American
energy we are in the best position we
have ever been in as it relates to any
conflict in the Middle East we are now
shielded from the crisis because of
course the lifeblood of every economy is
oil and gas not the new Green Deal and
the Iranian economy has lost value as we
have become energy independent we are
now the number one producer of oil and
natural gas for the first time in 75
years America is energy independent we
are a net exporter of energy in other
words we have their leverage we don't
need the Straits of Hormuz as we once
did and Iran is suffering economically
the Iranian people are growing more and
more angry and frustrated with their
radical government Iran's armed forces
cannot match the might of our military
now the mullahs must see the writing is
on the wall they either stop funding
terror proxy wars stop attacking ships
in the Gulf of Oman stop plotting the
annihilation of Israel our closest ally
in the Middle East and the
it states if they do not end this
hostility if they do not stop the
mullahs of Iran will feel pain
I predict like never before and it will
they will earn it they will make it
happen